I was like trying to put this binder on
in the bathroom at work and just stuck
like this thanks Jay I was like just
trapped a binder is like a chest
compressor that sort of just compacts
everything down so I remember being
anxious but also really excited because
I wasn't really comfortable wearing like
you know white tees or certain shirts
because it would show my my chest before
Top surgery and that caused a lot of
anxiety putting it over my head and my
friend said be careful because you will
get stuck I got really stuck and I was
like in some position like oh and I
couldn't get an arm and it was it was
very uncomfortable first time I got in
the wrong size way too small I didn't
know how to put it on I didn't really
understand how one is supposed to get
into this armor it all felt like
everything had just launched in the
middle and then I couldn't bring some
binders will push all of your fat down
into your belly and then till you'll
like have this like giant spare tire the
first time I went outside I felt so
happy because I would look down on my
chest I didn't feel like yes this is
what I want this is what I've wanted oh
my god like I don't have like boobs
right now this is amazing the way people
would see me was the way I wanted to be
seen it felt hot I felt all the good
things and then once I was ready to take
it off I got super scared because that
is also very difficult my girlfriend
helped me get it over my head so I
wouldn't get stuck again if you're gonna
do it definitely go to a binding a
company that makes binders no waste
bandages or anything like that don't use
duct tape unless you want your skin to
rip off oh my god
Safety's the find community where you
feel comfortable and safe talking about
it whether that's in person or online